I was a,
I was,
I've always been told that,
uh,
any serious introduction to political
philosophy has to start with a big piece
of Plato.
All right?
So we've,
we've made some effort to do that.
Uh,
but now also we have to move on.
So we moved to Plato's son is adopted
son in a manner of speaking Aristotle.
Uh,
there's a story about
the life of Aristotle.
Uh,
it goes something like this.
Aristotle was born,
he spent his life
thinking and then he died.
Uh,
there's obviously more
to his life than that.
Uh,
but to some degree,
this captures some of the way in which
Aristotle has been perceived over the
centuries.
That is to say the ultimate philosopher.
Aristotle was born in the year three 84,
uh,
15 years after the trial of Socrates,
who was born in the northern part of
Greece in a city called Sta Guiro,
which is part of what
is now called Macedonia.
It was called that then.
And when he was about your age,
when he was 17 or thereabouts,
maybe slightly younger than many of you.
Uh,
he was sent by his father
to do what you are doing.
He was sent by his
father to go to college.
Uh,
he was sent to Athens
to study at the academy.
The first university spoke
about established by,
by Plato.
But unlike most of you,
Aristotle did not spend four
years at the platonic academy.
He remained attached
to it for the next 20,
uh,
until the death of Plato and
after the death of Plato.
Uh,
perhaps because of the choice
of successors to the academy,
Aristotle left Athens,
uh,
first to re first for Asia minor and
then to return to his home in Macedonia
where he had been summoned by King
Philip to establish a school for the
children,
uh,
of the Macedonian ruling class.
And it was here that Aristotle
met and taught Phillip's son,
right?
Who,
who was Phillips of Macedonia,
his son Alexander.
You all remember the recent movie of a
year or two ago about Troy with Collin
Farrel about Alexander who
played Aristotle in that film.
Do you remember Anthony Hopkins?
Actual excellent.
He was,
he was a,
was it Anthony Hopkins?
I have in my notes here.
It was Christopher Palmer.
Okay.
I have to check.
I'll have to Google that when I go home,
but maybe it may be a ride.
Well,
I think I have a feeling
it wasn't Anthony Hopkins.
You're right.
Whoever it was an excellent,
Aristotle didn't have a large
enough part in the film.
In any case,
Aristotle returned to Athens later on
in established a school of his own,
uh,
arrival to the Platonic
Academy who did that?
He called the lyceum and there is a
story that near the end of his life,
Aristotle was himself brought up on
capital charges as with Socrates due to
another wave of hostility to philosophy,
but rather unlike Socrates rather
than staying to drink the hemlock,
Aristotle left Athens and
Rome was reported to have
said he did not wish to see
the Athenians sin against
philosophy for a second time.
I'll go back to that story in a minute
because I think it's very revealing about
Aristotle,
but in any way,
this story helps to underscore some I
think important differences between Plato
and Aristotle.
At one level you might say there is an
important difference in style that you
will see almost immediately unlike
his intellectual godfathers,
Socrates who wrote nothing but converse
endlessly and unlike his own teacher,
Plato who wrote imitations of this
endless Socratic conversations.
Aristotle wrote disciplined and thematic
treatises on virtually every topic from
biology to ethics to metaphysics
to literary criticism and politics.
One can assume safely that Aristotle would
have received tenure in any number of
departments at Yale.
Where is Socrates could not have applied
to have been a teaching assistant
and these differences conceal others
for Plato would same.
The study of politics was always
bound up with deeply philosophical and
speculative questions,
questions of metaphysics,
questions of the structure of the cosmos,
what is the soul?
What is,
what is,
what is the soul about?
Aristotle appears from the beginning to
look more like what we would think of as
a political scientist.
He collected constitutions 158 of them
all from throughout the ancient world and
was the first to give some kind of
conceptual rigor to the vocabulary of
political life.
Above all,
Aristotle's works like the politics and
the Nicomachean ethics were explicitly
intended as works of
political instruction,
political education.
They seem to be designed to to recruit
philosophers and potential philosophers
and to shape and educate
citizens and future statesmen.
His work seem less theoretical in a
sense of constructing abstract models of
political life.
Then advice giving in the sense of serving
as a sort of civic minded arbiter of
public disputes.
Unlike Socrates who famously in his image
in book seven of the Republic compared
political life to a cave and unlikely
apology or Socrates tells his fellow
citizens that their lives,
because unexamined are not worth living.
Aristotle takes seriously the dignity
of the city and showed the way that
philosophy might be useful
to citizens and statement.
Yet for all of this,
one might say there is still a profound
enigma surrounding Aristotle's political
works.
To put it simply,
one could simply ask,
what were the politics
of Aristotle's politics?
What were Aristotle's
own political beliefs?
Aristotle lived at the
virtual cusp of the,
uh,
world of the autonomous city,
state of the Greek Polis.
Within his own lifetime.
Aristotle would see Athens,
Sparta,
and the other great cities
of Greece swallowed up by
the Great Macedonian Empire
to the north.
What we think of as the
golden age of Greece was,
was virtually at an end,
uh,
during the lifetime of Aristotle.
Other Greek thinkers of his time,
notably a man named Demosthenes knees
wrote a series of speeches called
Philippics,
uh,
Anti Phillip,
to the north to warn his contemporaries
about the dangers posed to Athens from,
uh,
the imperial ambitions,
of Mastodon.
But Philips warnings came too late.
Uh,
and again,
the autonomous Greek Polis,
Plato and Glaucon at a,
a mantis and others would
have known came to an end.
What did Aristotle think of these changes?
What did he think was going on?
He is silent.
Aristotle,
extreme reluctance.
His hesitance
just to the issues of his time are
perhaps the result of his foreignness to
Athens.
He was not an Athenian and therefore
he lacked the protection of Athenian
citizenship.
At the same time you
might think his reticence,
his reluctance to speak in his own voice
may have also been a response to the
fate of Socrates and the politically
endangered situation of philosophy.
It for a man is notoriously
secretive and reluctant is Aristotle.
His works acquired over the
centuries virtual canonical status.
He became an authority really one
could say the authority on virtually
everything for Thomas Aquinas
who wrote in the 13th century.
Aristotle was referred to by Aquinas
simply as the philosopher was no reason
even to say his name.
He was simply the philosopher
and for uh,
the Great Jewish medieval philosopher,
Moses Maimonides.
Aristotle was called by him,
the master of those who know.
Think of that,
the master of those who know for
centuries Aristotle's authority seem to go
virtually unchallenged,
right?
You with me?
Yet
the authority of Aristotle obviously no
longer has quite the power that it once
did.
The attack began.
Not all that long ago really only is
late as the 17th century in a man who we
will re later this semester named
Thomas Hobbs was one who led the pack,
led the charge
in the 46 chapter of Leviathan chapter,
we will relator Hobbs road.
I believe that scares anything can be
more repugnant to government then much of
what Aristotle has said in his politics,
nor more ignorantly then a
great part of his ethics.
Think of that.
Nothing more repugnant to government
then what Hobbs wrote in his,
I mean that Aristotle
wrote in his politics
naturally,
all thinkers to some degree have read
Aristotle through their own lenses.
Aquinas read Aristotle is a defender
of monarchy and Dante in his book,
the Monarchia on monarchy.
So Aristotle was giving credence to the
idea of a universal monarchy under the
leadership of a Christian Prince,
but Hobbs,
sorry,
Aristotle,
quite differently.
For Hobbs,
Aristotle taught the dangerous doctrine
of Republican government that was seen
to be practice,
particularly during the Cromwellian
period in England during the civil war.
Aristotle's doctrine that
man is a political animal.
Hobbes believed could only
result result in did result.
In fact,
in regicide the murder of kings,
and there are certainly echoes of this
reading of Aristotle as a teacher of
participatory Republican government in
the later writings of democratic thinkers
from Tocqueville to Hannah Arent.
Anyway,
this return just to the
enigma of Aristotle who was
this strange and elusive man
who's writing seem to have been enlisted
boats for the support of monarchy and
for republics,
even for a universal monarchy and
smaller participatory democratic kind of
government.
Who was this man and how
to understand his writings?
Well,
the best place to start is of course with
his views stated in the opening pages
of the politics and the
naturalness of the city.
His claim,
that man is by nature
of the political animal,
right?
It's his famous claim.
What does that mean?
We are the political animal.
Aristotle states his reasons succinctly,
maybe to succinctly on the third page
of the politics where he remarks that
every city or every
policy exists by nature
and he goes on to infer from this.
That man is what he calls the Zohan.
Politik.
Yeah,
the political animal.
The Polis animal and his
reasoning here brief as it is,
is worth following.
Let me just quote him,
that man,
he's Tez is much more a political
animal than any kind of B or herd.
Animal is clear.
Why is it clear for we assert,
he says,
nature does nothing in vain and man
alone among the animals has speech
are other species he notes may have voice,
may have and be able to
distinguish pleasure and pain.
Speech logos is,
he is his word for it.
Man has logos,
reason or speech.
Word can mean either.
It's more than the ability simply to
distinguish pleasure and pain he goes on,
but logos he's writes serves to reveal
the advantageous and the harmful and
hence he writes the just and the unjust
for it is peculiar to man is compared to
other animals that he alone has
a perception of good and bad,
just and unjust and other things.
In other words,
he seems to be saying that it is speech
or reason logos that is able to both
distinguish and create
certain moral categories,
certain important moral
categories that we live by.
The advantageous,
the harmful.
The just and unjust in things of
this sort that constitute as he says,
a family and to Paula,
but that's Aristotle in what sense?
We could ask ourselves,
and I think you probably will
be asking in your sections,
in what sense is the city by nature and
in what sense are we political animals
by nature?
Aristotle appears to give two different
accounts in the opening pages of the
book that you might pay attention to.
In the literal opening.
He gives what looks like a kind
of natural history of the Polis.
He seems there to be a kind
of anthropologist writing
us a natural history.
The Polis is natural in the sense that
it is grown out of smaller and lesser
forms of Human Association.
First comes the family,
then an association of
families in a tribe,
then an associate,
a further association in a village,
and then you might say an association
of villages that create a Polish or a
city.
The Polis is natural in the
sense that it is an outgrowth,
the most developed form of
of Human Association in the
way that one used to see
in natural history museums.
These kind of a biological,
you know,
charts of human development from,
these uh,
you know,
lesser
forms of a life all the way up
to civilization in some way.
But there is,
and that is part of Aristotle's argument,
but there was this a second sense for
him and in some ways more important sense
in which he says the Polis is by nature.
It has natural,
the city has natural in that it allows
human beings to achieve and perfect what
he calls there tell us
that is to see their end,
their purpose.
We are political animals.
He says because participation in the
life of the city is necessary for the
achievement of human excellence,
for the achievement of our wellbeing.
A person who is without a city,
he says,
who is our Polis without a city must
either be a beast or a God that is to say
below humanity or above it.
Our political nature is our essential
characteristic because only by
participating in political
life do we achieve,
can we acquire the excellence's or the
virtues as he says that our ma that make
us what we are that fulfill our two
loss or fulfill our our perfection.
So when Aristotle says that man
is a political animal by nature,
he is,
he is doing more than simply
asserting just a truism or just some,
some platitude.
I mean in many ways he is advancing a
philosophic postulate of great scope and
power.
Although the full development of the
thesis is only left deeply embedded,
it doesn't fully develop it in this work
or in insane isn't saying that man is
political by nature.
Note that he is not saying,
although he has sometimes
taken to be saying this,
that he is not saying that there was some
kind of biologically implanted desire
or impulse that we have or share that
leads us to engage in political life.
That is to say
we do not.
He wants to say engage in politics to say
it's natural for us to do so is not to
say we engage in political life
spontaneously and avidly as you might say,
spiders,
spin webs or ants build and hills.
He is not a kind of socio biologist of
politics although he sometimes appears
this way when he says that man is a
political animal in some ways to the
contrary he says,
man is political because not because we
have some biological impulse or instinct
that drives us to participate in politics,
but he says because we are
possessed of the power of speech.
It is speech that makes us political
speech or reason in many ways far from
determining our behavior
in some kind of a,
again in some kind of
deterministic biological sense,
speech or reason gives us a kind of
freedom latitude in area of discretion in
our behavior,
not available to other species.
It is a reason or speech,
not instinct that makes us political,
but then the question is for Aristotle,
the question he poses for us is what
is the connection between logos?
The capacity for speech or
rationality into politics,
how are these two combined?
Okay.
Why does one lead to
or entailed the other?
Uh,
and in many ways he's not
making a causal claim so much.
He's not saying that it is because we
are rational creatures possessed of the
power of speech that causes
us to engage in politics.
He's saying more,
he has more of an argument
of the kind that one of the,
this attribute of logos actually entails.
Uh,
political life logos.
He makes this argument I think
because logos entails to
fundamentally human attributes.
The power to know first the power to know.
You could say the power to know is our
ability to recognize by sight members of
the same polis or city.
It is above all speech.
That in a way ties us to others
of our kind that we share,
not just the capacity for language in a
way a linguist a linguist might assert,
but that we share a certain common
moral language and it is this sharing of
certain common
conceptions of what the just
and unjust that make a city.
And it is that capacity to know.
And to recognize others who
share this language with us.
That is the first sense in which logos
entails politics but reason entails or
logos entails more than uh,
this capacity.
It also entails for Aristotle,
interestingly,
the power of love.
Okay.
We love those with whom we are most
intimately related and who are most
immediately present and invisible to us.
In many ways,
Aristotle believes our social and
political nature is not the result of
calculation as we will see in Hobbes,
Locke and other social contract theorists,
but such things as love,
affection,
friendship and sympathy or the grounds
of political life and are rooted in our
logos.
It his speech or his speech that allows
a sharing in these qualities that make
us fully human.
Yeah,
but to say,
of course that man is political by
nature is not just to say that we become
fully human by participating
with others in a city.
It means more than this.
The form of association that leads to
our perfection is net is necessarily
something particular Ristick.
The city is always a particular city.
It is always this or that particular city.
The Polis is Aristotle as well as Plato
clearly understand is a small society
what could be called
today a closed society,
a society that leads to our perfection
that leads us to complete and perfect our
t loss must be held
together by bonds of trust,
right?
A friendship of Camaraderie as society
based simply on the mutual calculation of
interests could not be a real
political society for Aristotle.
We cannot trust our people.
Aristotle seems to say trust can only
be extended to a fairly small circle of
friends and fellow citizens.
Only a small city,
small enough to begin to be governed by
relations of trust can be political in
Aristotle's sense of the term,
the alternative to the city.
The empire can only be ruled despotically.
There can be no relations of trust
in a large imperial despotism.
So what follows in one sense that what
Aristotle says that man is by nature a
political animal and
the city is by nature.
The city can never be a universal state.
It can never be something that
incorporates all of humankind.
It can never be a kind of cosmopolitans,
a world state or even a
League of states or nations.
Uh,
the universal state,
uh,
will never allow for or does not allow
for the kind of self perfection that is
small,
self-governing Polis.
We'll have the city is
Aristotle understands,
will always exist in a world with others,
cities or other states based on different
principles that might be hostile to
one's own.
That is to say not even the best city on
areas Aristotle's account can afford to
be without a foreign policy,
a good citizen of a democracy will not
be the good citizen of another kind of
regime.
Partisanship and loyalty to one's own
way of life are required by a healthy
city.
To put the argument in terms that Paula
Marcus from Plato's republic would have
known,
friend and enemy are this natural and
ineradicable categories of political life.
Just as we cannot be
friends with our persons.
So the city cannot be friends with or
other cities or the state with all other
states,
war and the virtues necessary for war are,
is natural to the city is are
the virtues of friendship.
Trust and camaraderie.
There are also a necessary,
yeah,
note that in the opening
pages of the book.
Okay.
Aristotle doesn't say anything yet about
what kind of city or regime is best.
All he tells us is that we are the Polis
animal by nature and that to achieve
our ends it will be
necessary to live in a polos.
But what kind of Polis,
how should it be governed by the one,
the few,
the many or some combination
of these three categories.
At this point we know only the most
general features of what a policy is.
It must be small enough to be governed
by a common language of justice.
It is not enough merely
to speak the same words,
but in a sense citizens must
have certain common experiences,
certain common memory and experience
that shape a city and the people,
the large polyglot,
multi ethnic communities of today would
not be for an Aristotle's account,
allow for sufficient mutual trust and
friendship to count as a healthy political
community.
So Aristotle seems to be offering,
in some respects,
a kind of criticism of the kind of states
with which we are our most familiar.
Think.
Think about that.
When you have your sections or when you
talk about this text with your friends,
what is Aristotle saying about us?
The citizens of such a city can only
reach their t Lois to perfection through
participating in the offices in
the ruling offices of a city,
and again,
a large cosmopolitan state may allow
each individual the freedom to live as he
or she likes.
But this is not the freedom.
This is not freedom as
Aristotle understands it.
Freedom only comes to the exercise
of political responsibility,
which means responsibility for and
oversight of one's fellow citizens and the
common good.
It follows for him that freedom
does not mean living as we like,
but freedom is informed by a certain
sense of restraint in awareness that not
all things are permitted,
that the good society will be one
that promotes a sense of moderation,
restraint and self control.
Self governance is Eddie.
Amanda says that are inseparable
from the experience of freedom.
So in many ways,
Aristotle,
their offers as does Plato,
a certain kind of critique of the modern
or even the ancient democratic theory
of freedom,
which is living,
living as one bikes.
So you can see these opening
pages of the book dense,
uh,
argument.
Being condensed in a very deep ways.
Carry a great deal of
freight is a lot in there.
Uh,
that needs to be unpacked.
And I've only tried to
do a little of that,
a little of that here with you today
to go over sort of what Aristotle,
uh,
is suggesting in this idea of man,
the Polis animal.
But whatever we may think about this view,
whether we like it or don't like
it or whatever your view might be,
we must also confront
another famous,
more like infamous doctrine.
It is also very much a part of book one.
I refer to his arguments for
the naturalness of slavery.
Aristotle tells us that
slavery is natural.
The naturalness of slavery is said to
follow from the belief that inequality,
inequality is the basic
rule between human beings.
Aristotle and Thomas Jefferson seem to
disagree over the basic fact of human
experience,
whether it's a quality or inequality,
if this is true,
Aristotle's politics seems to be,
seems to stand condemned.
Is the most anti democratic
book ever written?
Is that true?
Aristotle's claim about
naturalness seems to require,
as he told us,
slavery
the category you'll distinction of
humanity into masters and slaves.
How to understand that.
Again,
Aristotle's argument is deeply compact
and will be easily misunderstood if you
only read it once.
It will just as likely be
misunderstood if you read it three,
four,
five or 10 times.
If you are not attentive
to what he's saying,
miss learning to be closely.
What was Aristotle saying
in the first place?
It's important that we avoid,
I think two equally,
uh,
unhelpful ways of responding to this.
The first which one finds among many
modern day commentator as many kind of neo
Eris to [inaudible] we might call them.
It's just simply avert
our eyes from the harsh,
uh,
unappealing aspects of Aristotle's thought
and proceed as if he never actually
said or meant such things.
We need to avoid the
temptation in many ways,
understandable is it might be to airbrush
or sanitized Aristotle to make him
seem more politically
correct for modern readers.
And yet we should also avoid the
second equally powerful temptation,
which is to reject Aristotle out of
hand because his views do not correspond
with our own
question is what did
Aristotle mean by slavery?
What did he think was who or what
did he think was the slave by nature?
Until we understand what he meant,
we have no reason to either
accept or reject his argument.
The first point worth noting about this
is it Aristotle did not simply assume
slavery was natural
because it was practiced
virtually everywhere in the ancient world.
You will notice,
did he frames his analysis
in the form of the debate?
Yeah,
he says the outset of his argument.
There are,
there are some he says indicating this
is an opinion held by many people.
There are some who believe that slavery
is natural because ruling and being
ruled is it pervasive distinction
that one sees all societies,
uh,
practice.
But he says others,
others believed that the distinction
between net master and slave is not
natural,
but it's based on force or coercion.
Even in Aristotle's time it appears
slavery was a controversial,
uh,
institution and elicited very different
kinds of opinions and responses.
And here is one of those
moments when Aristotle,
as I indicated earlier,
seems most maddeningly openminded.
He's willing to entertain
arguments both for both,
both for and against the debate.
Aristotle agrees with those who deny
that slavery is justified by war or
conquest wars.
He remarks are not always just so
those who are captured in war cannot be
assumed to be justly
or naturally enslaved.
Similarly,
he denies that slavery is always
or only appropriate for non Greeks.
There are no,
he is saying racial or
ethnic characteristics that
distinguish the natural slave
from the natural master and
in a stunning admission,
he says,
listen to this,
that while nature may intend to
distinguish the free man from the slave,
he says the opposite often results.
Nature often misses the mark.
He says,
now we seem to be completely confused
if slavery is natural and if nature
intends to distinguish the slave from
the unfree for the free from the unfree,
how can nature missed the mark?
How can the opposite often result?
I mentioned this because
such complications should
alert the careful reader,
right?
We're trying to read carefully what does
Aristotle doing and making this same so
complicated.
At the same time,
Aristotle agrees with those who
defend the thesis of natural slavery
and his defense seems to
run something like this.
Slavery is natural because we cannot rule
ourselves without the restraint of the
passions.
Self rule means self restraint.
Restraint or self control is necessary
for freedom or self government.
And what is true,
he seems to suggest a about the restraint
over one's passions and desires is
true of restraint and control over others.
Just as he appears to be saying there
is a kind of hierarchy within the soul
restraint of the passion.
So does that psychological hierarchy
translate itself into a kind of social
hierarchy,
uh,
between different kinds of people?
The natural hierarchy then seems to be
a sort of hierarchy of intelligence of,
or at least a hierarchy of the rational.
But how did this come to be?
Aristotle asks,
how is it that some people came to
acquire this capacity for rational self
control that is necessary for
freedom and others seem to lack it?
How did that come to be?
Is this hierarchy again a genetic quality?
Is it something we're born with?
Is it something that is implanted
in us by nature in that sense?
Or is that distinction something that
is created by nurture and education?
What we would call today
may be socialization.
And if the ladder,
if this hierarchy of intelligence
or this hierarchy of the rational,
uh,
is a result of upbringing,
then how can slavery be defended?
Is Natural.
There's an Aristotle calm man,
the rational animal,
the being with logo,
suggesting that all human beings have a
desire for knowledge and the desire to
cultivate their minds
and live as free persons.
Isn't there a kind of egalitarianism,
so to speak,
built in to the conception of
rational animal and political animal?
Uh,
he begins his metaphysics,
his great book,
the metaphysics with the
famous opening statement.
All men have a desire to know
if we all have a desire to know,
doesn't this connote something
universal that all should be free,
that all should participate in ruling
in being ruled as citizens of a city.
Yet at the same time,
Aristotle seems to regard education
is the preserve of the field
to kind of discipline and self restraint
necessary for an educated mind,
uh,
appears for him to be unequally
divided among human beings.
It follows,
I think that the regime
according to nature,
it is to say the best regime would be
what we might think of as an aristocracy
of,
of the educated an aristocracy of
education and training in Aristocratic
Republic of some sort that governs.
We're an educated elite governance for
the good of all Aristotle's republic.
Uh,
and I use that term to
remind you of Plato as well,
but Aristotle's republic is devoted
to cultivating a high level of citizen
virtue where this means those qualities
of mind and heart necessary for self
government.
These qualities he believes are the
preserve of the few of a minority,
of a minority capable of sharing in the
administration of justice and in the
offices of a city.
It seems to be a very elite teaching.
Would you agree
and an appealing to us
perhaps for that reason?
Very contrary to our intuitions and
the way we have been brought up.
Yes.
Yeah.
You agree with me,
but
before we dismiss Aristotle's account
is insufferably in a Galitary Ian in
elitist,
we have to ask a difficult question,
not just of Aristotle,
but more importantly of ourselves.
What else is Yale
but in elite institution
intended to educate
morally and intellectually
potential members of a leadership class?
Think about that.
Can anyone get into Gail?
Do we have an open admissions policy
for all who want to come here?
Hardly.
Does it not require those
qualities of self control,
discipline and restraint
necessary to achieve success here?
I will leave aside for the moment.
What happens on Friday
and Saturday nights?
Is it any coincidence that graduates
from this university in a handful of
others,
not unlike it,
find themselves in high
positions of government,
of business,
of law,
and the academy.
Is it unfair or unreasonable to describe
this class is Aristotle might as a
natural aristocracy.
So I leave you with this
question to think about
before we reject Aristotle is
an anti democratic elitist.
Take a look at yourselves.
So are you,
or you wouldn't be sitting here today.
Think about that and
I'll see you next week.